this summer nature joined 60 Nobel
laureates and 600 students at the lindau
meetings on Lake Constance in Germany
they were celebrating 60 years of these
unique meetings an annual meeting of
minds a meeting of young and old
investigating the frontiers of science
and its impact on the world first we
made for films featuring some of the
best young scientists exploring the work
and ideas of their selected laureates
absolutely again the water stage and am
now in the last year of my PhD uh-huh
and what are you working on I'm working
on systems biology network biology haha
I think it's kind of a nice
complementary approach to the
traditional reductionistic way of
approaching biological problems I think
it's good to have a dialogue yeah
exactly exactly so I think both sides
ought to spend more time talking to it
yeah yeah so until you and a little bit
dubious about systems biology these sort
of static pictures of what interacts
with what I don't find very illuminating
you can't even tell whether they're true
or not actually it's another serious
serious issues as far as I'm concerned
everything comes from an observation
yeah in the first place a reproducible
observation and then you just sort of
follow it wherever it goes and you asked
questions about it that's just the kind
of scientist I am whether that's good or
bad I mean different people are
different right
so you've got a sort of truffle around
and turn over stones and sort of notice
that's all things don't quite make sense
and sometimes that's more of a gut
reaction than a than something you know
so what about people from like multiple
feels like I'm double majoring in
biology and chemical engineering well
that's great and maybe you're the this
Linda meeting has a fantastic group of
researchers here they obviously been
very carefully selected they're all very
smart they all ask a lot of questions so
it's been really fun talking to them
Jack Shostak is a biologist his current
research interests are in the origins of
life once life gets started it can adapt
and evolve and colonize many many
different environments our astronomer
friends discovered already over 400
earth-like planets and the question of
whether there might be life out there
and those other worlds really boils down
to the question of whether it's easy or
hard to make that transition from the
chemistry of an early planet to the
beginnings of biology your research you
know but from cheering you speak
yesterday is very much curiosity driven
right and no real practical application
that's okay for a long time anyway I
thing I can foresee it we were talking
about the issue of the kinds of
molecules that came together to make the
first living cells and in particular the
fact that a lot of these molecules come
in two forms that are mirror images of
each other but in modern biology we
generally see only one of those mirror
image forums so there's been a
long-standing question as to how that
got started
vol the laureates here I believe there
are only three women and one is actually
also as bavasie see who is the french
scientist who discovered the link
between HIV and AIDS we we love to face
a global scale epidemic we know to death
at 42 patients starting treatment there
is five new case of infection and still
there is 2.7 million new cases of
infection to a year and you wrote you
wrote a letter right to the Pope that's
right what was the the content of that
letter what motivated you to do
something like that the pool make a
statement saying that condom we are not
efficient to prevent against HIV and we
have to stop this kind of statement I
mean it's criminal is destroying in few
minutes all the work done by others but
I'm glad to say that visit ease and
countries in Africa where religious are
working they distributed by themselves
the condom the day of my wedding I was
in the lab
I receive a phone call from who became
my husband at eleven thirty in the
morning saying do you think you will
come what advice do you have for women
who are trying to pursue careers in
science in the midst of a you know
social climate that's still somewhat
male-dominated and where women still
have roles that are expected to be
fulfilled select the right bone
Hamilton Smith's initial work that led
to the Nobel Prize was restriction
enzymes and that allowed manipulation of
DNA which open up a whole new field of
cutting and cloning and analyzing DNA
but then came some work he did on
sequencing DNA so being able to take an
organism and say what's its blueprint
that's an entirely new way of thinking
and led to the Human Genome Project what
motivates us is almost the science
fiction of autonomous medical tools
Fineman talked about the surgical micro
robot so you could swallow the surgeon
and it would make decisions and cut out
a cancer things like that so we're
trying to demonstrate some of the tools
that may be useful to build some of
these things so we build little micro
grippers that are about a millimeter in
diameter that start out flat and when we
want them to be triggered they can
trigger and grab something and we've
shown we can do little in vitro biopsies
so these are very small robotic things
that would be introduced attached to a
very thin wire well that's what makes
them very interesting there tabulous oh
really yeah so so that's that's really
it's getting incredible I think it's
it's pretty yeah we just I work on it
for months and you kind of lose sight of
it the fact that you're really working
on something weird everything he's doing
is new to me I had no idea that people
were working on this he was interested
very much and what I've been doing with
synthetic cells I think partly because
he's trying to see how it might be
helpful in his own work I wanted ask you
about the recent paper that's just been
published online with craig Venter about
the synthetic cell so this was a large
technical challenge it seems to just
make the DNA or this size yo it's a
technical achievement would you consider
yourself an engineer in practical terms
and how you are building a synthetic
cell this was a very I'm glad to hear
that as an engineer we're the right feel
a fantastic thing to hear and this year
also marking the 60th anniversary we
made a special documentary to celebrate
the spirit of Linda the spirit of lindau
is the combination of scientific
excellence deep passion for science
curiosity and the inside that science
does not provide final answers after the
Second World War the Yama's had been
isolated for quite some time so to
doctors here in lindau in this medieval
town which is behind me they decided
they wanted to invite some Nobel
laureates in physiology or medicine to
come here and to tell them what had
happened during the wall there was a
tremendous feeling and atmosphere of
wanting to break out of the isolation
that happen experience and wanting to
move forward and wanting to make
connections again and then this
brilliant idea came on we should invite
young people students young researchers
and we should get them together with
Annabelle
I think there's no question that the
beauty of lindau with its wonderful
lakeside setting is an inspiration for
everybody and it is part of the reason
why people unwind here and enter into
the spirit of informality which i think
is so crucial you have outstanding
people and you have keen capable young
scientists I remember here at lid now
once a student told me you know what's
wrong with scientists you're never sure
of anything you ask them to say yes well
we think that and she said that that's
one of the weaknesses of science and I
told him this is one of the god of
science this idea that you might be
wrong